i don't know how oda does it but he
seems to more often than not make the
absolute most out of every situation he
places his characters within
every scene every encounter and every
single set piece serves the story and
makes it all
so incredibly interesting and fun to
read through after the heartbreaking
tension-filled excitement the last arc
ended on i was sort of anxious to see
how the narrative was going to progress
but it just keeps getting better from
the vibrant vistas of amazon lily to the
cramped corridors of impul down
the tension of the occasion mixed with
the exemplary storytelling odaflexes on
chapter by chapter
is a feast for the eyes and the mind and
in this video i will be attempting to
describe
how unbelievably exciting and fantastic
these arcs are
so without further ado i'm totally not
mark and these are my first impressions
on thoughts of
and review for the intensely interesting
and masterfully composed
amazon lily and impul down
[Music]
so last week it came to my attention
that uh i might have forgotten to
mention a certain character
and yeah i get it he's important okay so
in my defense
i only just met him and while he was
revealed yes we also met
this guy and uh this happened so i was a
little preoccupied with stuff that was
immediately happening and more often
than not i
couldn't care less about how a character
looks or how flashy they really are and
in this case the pun is absolutely
intended but you guys wanted me to say
something so
here it is the angry admiral man enters
the chat while riding a cannonball
which is a cool visual reminiscent of
tao from dragon ball that i enjoyed he
did fight with the supernovas for a bit
but i have no idea how strong they are
relative to each other so
i don't really learn much about him or
them from that particular exchange we
learn about his devil fruit ability
which is pretty flashy
pun intended again both he and okiji
seem to share a personality trait of
being quite nonchalant which does well
to establish a certain confident
presence as for the supernovas i don't
have anything to say about them beyond
what i already did in my last video i
get that people wanted me to talk about
cazarro and these guys more than i
vaguely did in my last video but the
fact remains
at this point in the story they are only
just being introduced if they become
something significant in the future i'll
mention them then but until such time
they directly influence the story beyond
showing up and fighting i'll
be sure to discuss them in more detail i
mean for instance when i met blackbeard
for the very first time i
almost didn't mention him in my script
and it's like that by design
oda as a writer plants tons of seeds as
he writes the one piece story
and i recognize that cazaro is an
admiral and that the supernovas are
significant but while writing the video
last week i didn't have
anything substantial to say about them
beyond recapping the events
if certain characters don't impact the
story enough or strike my fancy as much
as i want them to
then i just won't talk about them and
it's nothing to do with the character
it's just that i don't have anything to
say necessarily about them in that
moment but if they show up later i will
be sure to mention them then
alright let's go to the jungle
this brief but insightfully and
delightfully compelling story arc
surrounding luffy was
i found uniquely engaging and once i
finished what this arc had to offer i
was very impressed with what it did for
the story
not just because it exposes some very
interesting and eye-opening lore that i
will most definitely be discussing later
in this video but it also provided an
emotionally rich patch of respite amidst
this turbulent saga we
currently find ourselves in deciding to
explore luffy's emotional state the
whereabouts of the crew and his ultimate
plan to circumvent his predicaments and
to ultimately decide he needs to save
his brother from his doomed fate
first for the first time since the very
first chapters
luffy is very much alone having
cultivated an endearing and loving crew
of friends to surround himself with
against all odds over the last 500 some
odd chapters
this arc opens with luffy flying through
the air before landing deep in the
jungle of amazon lily a brand new
island completely isolated which firstly
i would like to question the allegiance
of kuma as a warlord of the sea
or if he is in fact doing what he was
told to do by sending him there
maybe it's important for luffy and the
crew to remain alive but to be very very
separate but anyway back to the story at
hand it's in these first opening
chapters and challenges that luffy is
presented with on this
unfamiliar island that we or at least i
got a very different feeling while going
through it there's a sort of off-balance
and desperate
feeling that paints luffy's every effort
and that's one of the strongest
attributes this arc has working in its
favor
it's goal this story acts as an
immediate continuation to the horrific
events that took place in the
archipelago a mere chapter ago
and follows luffy as he tries to find
and regroup with his crew with an
incredibly lonely
heir to the occasion towards the
beginning and the notion of being able
to regroup with his friends is made all
the more possible due to one fantastic
mechanic being brought back to light the
life papers in his possession
radius points back towards the
archipelago and aces directly towards
his location
in impel down right off the bat we are
made aware of the dilemma luffy faces
quite literally he needs to choose which
path to follow and while initially it's
obvious
as he at this point doesn't see the
urgency to help out his brother ace but
as the story progresses it becomes
abundantly clear that he can't follow
the path that leads him back to his
friends just yet but instead needs to
deal with his family and it's down this
path through both this arc amazon lilly
and
impel down thereafter that we begin
learning more and more about luffy's
family and his past
but i'm getting a little ahead of myself
here in trying to formulate a plan in
order to get back to civilization and
ultimately the crew at the archipelago
we see luffy incapacitate himself by
eating the wrong sort of mushroom
leading him to be
discovered by a group of women native to
this island they bring him back to their
village thinking that he too was a woman
however once they removed the last
mushroom from his body to their surprise
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm not exactly sure if this is relevant
here but while i was learning about and
being exposed to the culture and customs
of this island's tribe
i noticed that their currency was go
g-o-l
which is the first time i noticed
something having the same word
or name as a key character maybe it has
some significance moving forward
regarding gold d roger but
maybe it doesn't i don't know it's just
money as the story progresses there's a
fantastic piece of subtle character
writing on display once luffy regains
consciousness within the tribe
the very first thing he asks about once
he comes to is about his friends
and the second is his hat subtly showing
his personality traits
and priorities as a character that i
really enjoyed when i noticed it however
once he wakes up
in a confusion he starts demanding
information before
breaking out taking with him the very
girl who replaced the clothes he was
wearing with these new ones
these nice flowery new ones specifically
he takes her because she has the life
paper he needs to find where he needs to
go next
which is a beautiful means of
interweaving the plot with the
characters to force them into believable
circumstances
allowing us the audience to learn more
about this girl without it feeling
forced this arc works ridiculously well
in that regard too
the motivations decisions and
interactions that take place therein
feel so perfect and real and i think
that's because there are so few things
to keep track of
in this arc when you compare it to all
the rest with luffy for the most part
being the only character that was known
of before going into this
and you'd be forgiven for thinking that
this would mean that this arc would feel
like a
sort of filler in a lot of aspects but
it really isn't and i can't stress that
enough
this is one of the best setup arcs in
the entire series
and during these innocent interactions
between luffy and this girl
luffy learns of ace's fate and she
learns that luffy isn't anyone to be
scared of or wary of anymore she informs
luffy of the location ace now finds
himself in how the island they are on is
within the cam belt surrounded by
neptunians and that one of the only ways
off the island is on a particular ship
this extravagant character becomes the
focus of a chapter or two
when a vice admiral that goes by the
name of momongo arrives to summon
hancock to marine ford apparently all
the warlords of the sea are expected to
be
on hand for aces execution and those
that do not attend
will have their titles revoked so yeah
she's a warlord of the sea apparently
which is
awesome and her introduction in this
scene is fittingly impactful
flat out refusing to fight in the
impending war and informs the vice
admiral that not only will she keep her
title and privileges but she will also
take his cargo and treasure
which i mean come on it's a pretty
mental move through this interaction
it's also revealed that she has the
devil fruit ability to turn those that
find her attractive to stone the vice
admiral prevents this from happening
however by stabbing his
own hand getting major chad vibes from
this dude but gives her just two days
and after that if she doesn't comply her
titles and position will be revoked
in the meantime however he will wait in
the harbor essentially for all intents
and purposes
boa hancock is the leader of this island
of women and along with her two sisters
they are seen as the three higher-ups of
this civilization
and if luffy wants to get off this rock
he needs her ship
and help which leads to a funny
character moment for luffy wherein he
climbs to the top of the tallest
building because
and i quote that's where important
people are
before falling through the roof into the
bath chamber of hancock
where he gets a glimpse of her back and
i should also explain that no one can
see her back due to the apparent
presence of a gorgon's eye that would
turn those that do see it
to stone immediately but interestingly
luffy recognizes it and it's not a
gorgon's eye
however in all of this confusion and
shock hancock tries to turn him to stone
but
it has zero effect on luffy which is a
fun bit of character writing because he
doesn't find her attractive at all
unlike literally everyone else in this
world apparently but easily the most
interesting and eye-opening part of this
arc for me
has to be this scene
this changes everything hacky has been
hinted at throughout this series but
what luffy demonstrated here shutting
down a crowd of people is something i've
only seen with shanks before
[Applause]
which leads me down all sorts of
interesting rabbit holes that might be
worth exploring and predicting the
future
and recontextualizing the past events of
the series the snake warriors he faces
off against in this battle to the death
have variations of the hacky power
but in this moment of stress he
activates within himself a power that
according to hancock is an incredibly
rare power
only seen maybe once in millions of
people this particular power is referred
to by them as the haki
of the supreme king which i mean
but here's my theory on this put on your
speculation hats because i'm about to
blow the whole lid on this thing
this civilization of women on this
island refer to devil fruit abilities as
cursed powers they don't know it so they
have their different terminology for
various things
what if the haki of the supreme king is
actually
king of the pirates and what if goldie
roger had this exact same ability or
trait that we're not necessarily aware
of yet regardless
what makes this interesting is that it
perhaps gives reason as to why
shanks found himself hanging around
luffy for years and years
maybe goldie roger knew that luffy would
be important to protect
i mean he's referred to as the future
sometimes in the story but for someone
like shanks to give
up his arm to protect him like that is a
really
interesting move not just because luffy
could be very important but
also because surely shanks could have
easily taken out that sea monster that
did that to his arm maybe he knew that
this would motivate luffy to take on the
path that he did
or perhaps luffy has another power that
nullifies the haki of other users
i mean it was a stressful incident for
him and i haven't even touched on the
likelihood of hacking being used on the
blade of someone like hawkeye we already
learned that hackie can coat the outside
of weapons in this story too
but whatever i'm getting a little lost
in the weeds here so let's move on
before i completely dive off the deep
end
despite all of this lore speculation my
favorite aspect of this story is how
subtle it is when it comes to informing
us of luffy's current predicament and
mindset
throughout his time in amazon liddy he's
found himself in various circumstances
where he misses
individual crew members not just from a
friendship point of view but also a
utilitarian point of view painting for
us
a much more solemn picture of luffy's
predicament while also reinforcing the
notion that he's only here because of
the crew he built around him using all
of their strengths in conjunction with
his own
to get where they did today and so while
stumbling and bouncing around from place
to place in amazon lilly he finds
himself eating bad food that sanji could
have prevented he finds himself failing
to build a means of sailing away that
frankie could have provided he realizes
that even if he did sail away he'd have
no chance of finding where he needs to
go because nami's navigation is
something that he cannot do himself and
even when
faced with hurt or injured friends in
this story he makes mention that chopper
would be invaluable in this instance
these are really nice bits of subtle
emotional writing that keeps the crew
at the forefront of our minds and puts
into perspective for us
how much they mean for him and the story
and speaking of emotional this story
packed a few of those too for such a
short tale it does well in establishing
characters to care about while hinging
it all on our appreciation for luffy as
a character
for instance the main point of
contention in this arc comes as luffy
fights the two snake sisters
after hancock turn luffy's friend and
the other two tribeswomen to stone
after they vouch for him and his good
intentions and so once luffy wins the
fight
while also protecting the marks on their
backs from the audience watching
he puts not only the sisters he's
fighting in their places
but also puts hancock in a really
difficult situation
as explained within her backstory she
finds it incredibly hard to trust most
people
specifically men which once we do hear
her story is understandable given what
she's gone through and before i get any
comments about it i know i'm not
mentioning fisher tiger
there's just too much stuff to go over
in this particular instance her
backstory was
really really interesting but
essentially she and her sisters as well
as thousands of slaves were freed by
someone that climbed the red line
with his bare hands and that person was
called fisher tiger
i have no idea who this person is and i
certainly have no idea what implications
he might have for the story moving
forward
but in one last effort to expose luffy
as a selfish person
concerned with only his own goals she
offers him a dilemma
either she can take him to where he
needs to go to save his brother or she
can return those women who stood up to
her on luffy's behalf
back to normal and after an entire arc
of following luffy experience what it's
like to be alone
isolated from his comrades he chooses
without hesitation
and with a relieved smile on his face
for her to save the three women
and the very fact that that was such a
non-issue for luffy
honestly had me welling up while i was
reading
it's a beautiful moment and it's that
very aspect of luffy's identity that
rather ironically causes hancock to
become infatuated with them
as a love interest leading her to storm
away in the naval vessel
to facilitate his rescue of ace in
impel down
[Music]
so tell me does he give you nice doggie
biscuits when he wants you to play
fetch and you all buck no bite
[Music]
you're not funny
this is probably the most narratively
dense arc in per volumes red but despite
this it's actually an incredibly simple
story filled to bursting with character
compelling team-ups and a very real
sense of tension and dread that builds
up until the very end wherein it meets a
very satisfying crescendo but not the
main crescendo that's next week but as i
said
this arc is incredibly dense and
detailed so in order to protect my
sanity i've decided to split it up into
four sections so
let's get it section one getting to ace
for all intents and purposes the input
down arc of one piece is a fully
realized prison break story
during which oda as per the huge
establishes the area by way of maps
careful scene selection
and brute force and what i mean by brute
forces luffy ends up causing
so much trouble in this damn building
that everything gets thrown
at him and of course those he
accumulates to his side
during this jailbreak and trust me by
the time this arc is over you'll be able
to draw a detailed image of this place
with
99 accuracy without even popping a
reference well
maybe that's a little bit of an
exaggeration but the point still stands
stuff goes down in this arc literally
and
figuratively because they're literally
going down never mind
and what makes this prison break night
impossible to pull off are
these factors that we've been aware of
from the very beginning of the story it
is
much like the amazon lilly arc situated
on the calm belt surrounded by
neptunians
behind the biggest doors i've ever seen
ever
it's guided by some of the most powerful
and imposing folks in the universe of
one piece
oh and uh did i mention that the entire
facility is
underwater you know water the thing
devil fruit wielders can't find
themselves in
yeah well that's all around it and
what's more is that ace
is at the very bottom and to be honest
all of these mechanics have been
understood by us since the very
beginning or around therein but have
never been used all
in conjunction with one another to
create such an impenetrable fortress for
luffy to infiltrate but maybe my
favorite aspect at the beginning is the
nature of how luffy gained entry into
impul down in the first place
this is of course a maximum security
prison built to contain some of the most
dangerous people in the world
it's never been broken into and
certainly no one has escaped
and i just love this because the only
reason luffy can break into this place
successfully
is by being a truly good person he was a
truly truly good person to hancock
convincing her to escort him by way
giving him entrance to the building in
the first place the prison is for
dangerous and evil people luffy is
neither of those things i love that
someone with those qualities
created the very first blemish in the
facility's history and once he separates
from hancock luffy begins what ends up
being one of the most physically taxing
and actually no scratch that this is 100
the most physically taxing experience he
has ever had to deal with since the
story began
discovering that the facility is
multi-layered with each subsequent
deeper layer housing more and more
dangerous personnel
with increasingly harsh qualities for
instance level 1 has a
forest made entirely of pointy things
while lower levels have
well pretty much hell which you know not
ideal
but as it happens on his way through all
of these floors he meets
quite a few faces from the past to help
him in his endeavour
on level one luffy hooks up with and get
this buggy the freaking clown which
was so cool to see and to be honest it
offered a lot in the way of comedy with
this panel having me in
stitches while reading i'll let you be
the ones to read that if you want but i
just loved it
and that joke only works now because we
understand how small of a player buggy
is in the grand scheme of things
or is he and after each subsequent level
they reach
more and more faces from the past rear
their heads to join his cause with level
one and two offering a buggy as i said
and mr three if you believe it and it's
in these scenes with luffy mr three and
buggy that some of the best comedic
moments are on display
buggy had the intention of only taking
luffy as far as the entrance in exchange
for an important armband that nami gave
him but no matter what buggy and
ultimately mr
three do they always find themselves
unintentionally
following luffy down through the depths
deeper and deeper and deeper as luffy
plunges himself further and further into
the hellish chambers of this
increasingly more dangerous impel down
coming face to face with tons of
security and bluegreen not to mention
the
roaming beasts and the warden the
facility but more on him later
first we got to see this guy oh come on
that's right it's time for one piece's
best boy
the charming the beautiful bon clay and
to be honest this section of the story
had
ingenious uses for buggy mr three and of
course bon clay both comedically and
narratively providing so much
entertainment and substance to the
overall story
creating along the way a very different
and unique team for luffy to surround
himself with
which again only happens because of who
luffy is as a character
because of who luffy is all of these
one-time enemies find themselves either
having to or wanting to follow his lead
which on its own is a nice touch but
because we've already spent so much time
with the established straw hacked cast
it's a nice change of pace seeing how
all of these new powers bounce off each
other through the various imposing and
intense challenges that impul down
provides them with curious moments where
luffy's hacky might have even been used
a number of times against animals in the
building
so much is happening i don't even know
how to contain myself or process it oh
and they take down a minotaur that looks
kind of like a cow too
but no battle was more imposing or
brutal than luffy's battle with
warden magellan on level four this fight
is
hard to watch and what's weird is that
this warden magellan seems like a very
reasonable and likable character
so given my understanding of this world
now there are good and bad folks on
both sides it seems aside from the world
government who seem to be the most shady
and corrupt by far
in fact i'm not even sure i've met
anyone from their side that's actually
not just a really bad or sketchy
individual the navy has tons of good
characters like garp and smoker but
also contains some dangerous people too
that i'm unsure of yet the more i read
one piece the more it starts to feel
like good game of thrones
only no one really dies or maybe i'm
speaking too soon i don't know the devil
fruit ability of magellan happens to be
that of poison and in combat with luffy
despite his best efforts leaves him for
dead
which highlights another aspect of one
piece i utterly adore
luffy loses on a semi-regular basis like
he can actually lose in a devastating
manner which just
adds so much tension not only to this
arc but the rest of the series and
what's to come in the future
ace's situation for the most part ace
hasn't played a
massive role in the main story until
this saga instead he sort of appeared
sporadically throughout the manga during
specific key instances wherein he acted
as a measuring stick for luffy an
incredibly flashy character
and a component that served to remind me
that all the characters involved in the
story are active during and after their
time
on screen or in the main narrative but
as soon as blackbeard apprehended him
and turned him in to become a warlord of
the sea
ace has become a much more important
character in the story one that now acts
and main goal of the plot and to be
honest ace is a character right now i
don't really know too much about yet but
what i do love about him is what he
means as being a plot device
he is the perfect intersection of all
the main parties involved in this epic
power struggle for supremacy over the
oceans
there's the navy that haven't been
shackled and have invested interest in
taking him down there are the
revolutionaries led by his father
monkey d dragon and of course whitebeard
whom he worked under for a very long
time and because of him acting as a
point of interest for all of these
individual parties it not only serves to
be a great motivating factor for the big
power players in the story but also
facilitates new pieces of info to be
released to us about them
albeit in subtle ways there's a rather
interesting and somewhat illuminating
scene between ace and his grandfather
garp
as ace himself lies shackled in a
maximum security holding cell
in that ace reveals that he's both aware
of and resents his father which is
interesting as luffy doesn't seem to
hold
any grudge and by all accounts doesn't
even remember what he looks like but
perhaps the most interesting aspect of
this exchange comes when garp tries to
explain to ace that his father had his
reasons which
makes me question garp's allegiance to
the navy that's sort of a weird thing
for someone in his position to say i
would think he already shouldn't be
where he is talking two ways but
here we are it's a really interesting
turn of events and we still have no idea
who luffy and ace's mother
was or is and all of this serves pretty
much to once again bring the situation
to the forefront
all the straw hats are scattered across
the world and the war
seems to be imminent and what's more is
much later in the story we learn what
other detainees are held alongside ace
there are three of note
and they are sure you and jimbei croc i
think it goes without saying i was
already very familiar with and it's cool
to see him again apparently he's still
very driven and once he finds out about
all the mobilization he makes it known
that he wants to kill white beard too
sheer you on the other hand is a new
character who is described as being a
savage one-time jailer that worked in
impel down once upon a time but was
thrown in the cell
for being far too ruthless which is
interesting i think and the final
character i mentioned was jinbe
the final warlord of the sea that we
have not seen yet that is also a fishman
that respects whitebeard for bringing
peace to his people
he seems very interesting to me and he
too wants peace and with that he even
acknowledges shortcomings within his own
civilization of people
and later on in the story apologizes on
behalf of arlon
which is honestly kind of crazy to think
about and combining that with the fact
that the whitebeard pirates are making a
move on the navy
kaido another emperor of the sea is
making moves to take out whitebeard and
while this is all happening shanks is
trying to stop kaido i still don't know
what shanks's goal is here besides
trying to maintain peace is there a
reason why he's trying to maintain peace
i wonder if he might have more skin in
the game than we might realize but yeah
there are tons of things to consider
going on in the wider world that aren't
yet connecting to the immediate story so
i thought i'd throw them onto this
section so that i wouldn't get bogged
down in the details later on i can't
wait for all of this to go down
something big is definitely happening
luffy's recovery
this segment acts as the lull right
before we head for the big climax and i
honestly find it to be
very cool pun intended one of the
motivating factors bon clay was working
towards alongside luffy was the release
of a particular character he called
eva a so-called miracle worker his words
not mine however in an act of tremendous
selflessness
bon clay carries the poisoned luffy
moments from death in an effort to find
a cure to his terminal situation
despite mr three and buggy after running
away and deserting them both
eventually he loses consciousness
himself in the middle of a snowy
wilderness despite the power of luffy
keeping some wolves away in a very
curious way
i guess that's his hacky power once
again he's getting better at that but
once mr banclay awakes
we are introduced to a new area within
the prison wherein a vast variety of
freedom fighters and former prisoners
find themselves
after creating a small civilization
within these self-made crawl spaces
between floors 5
and 6 off impel down there bond meets
eva
the person who saved them and put luffy
into a potentially survivable state but
what makes this all the more interesting
is that throughout the entire time we've
been in impul down
every few chapters we are reminded of
the dwindling time before ace's
impending execution
acting as a countdown of swords for us
the reader which also creates its own
tension and sense of urgency to add to
the occasion but by far the most
compelling part of this section comes
during the window of time within which
luffy's body is in agony fighting off
the effects of the poison for hours
and hours on end he is screaming in
unbelievable pain but despite doing so
all through the night bon clay stays
with him outside his door
cheering on his efforts to beat this
thing for 20
hours despite bon clay at the time
thinking and believing that
luffy only had a 2 chance at the time of
survival
but in typical luffy fashion he beats
the poison in record time
devours an absurd amount of food and is
ready to go
well not really this emergency treatment
required luffy to take
10 years off of his life which just
makes me all sorts of anxious
and even after expelling all the poison
from his body and easing an ungodly
amount of food he still
is incredibly fatigued however once
again thankfully eva
increase adrenaline only once it wears
off in 24 hours he will crash
hard so looking forward to that but i
think the takeaway from this scene is
just how much of an
awesome character and all around great
guy bon clay is
but anyway bottom line get ace out we
still have some time
[Music]
[Applause]
okay they are too late um ace is already
being escorted out of the building
getting out again this section is my
favorite part of the story and is by far
and away the most
dense and i think of the many aspects
working in this section's favor that
works perhaps the best is that there are
so many mini stories
after being established and once
established as an audience we wait to
see how the story progresses with these
and interweaves them into the narrative
however
despite arriving too late to spring his
brother from prison he still has the
chance to grab him before they take him
to marine fort
but they need muscle they need more help
than what they currently have
in order to even get out of this
underwater bunker alone however
thankfully the area they find themselves
within isn't exactly short of talent
i can't tell you how cool it was
watching croc
fight alongside luffy and i freaking
love how nonchalantly is pretty much
about everything he does
also where does he get these cigars
never mind
and while the epic action is happening
with team luffy as they barge their way
through the various floors in the
compound
sure you the dangerous and corrupt
jailer from before gets the attention of
one of the officers in the prison
and convinces them to let him go to let
him help them to regain control of the
facility naturally they oblige but okay
[Music]
this bit is brilliant so you know the
way bon clay and luffy had their own
little troubles to deal with for the
last 20 some odd hours
well in typical oda fashion both mr
three and buggy had their very own
little adventure off-screen where they
managed to sneak up to floor two
using their combined powers and teamwork
and while on their way through the
various levels they have been freeing
prisoners in an attempt to cause enough
of a distraction to escape themselves
however as they continue to free
prisoners buggy manages to accumulate a
massive following
which again is just super funny and this
is where something
super interesting happens so as it
happens despite all the warlords
supposedly being ordered to be at marine
ford
blackbeard is missing when suddenly
[Applause]
as luffy is holding off and trying to
defeat one of the officers of the prison
on level four
out of nowhere cuts in blackbeard wiping
everyone out blackbeard pretty much
fills luffy in on what he's done to his
brother
causing luffy to land a massive hit on
the pirate leading blackbeard to remark
that he's stronger than he thought and
that his haki is stronger than it was
last time too
which means that blackbeard can sense
hacky and the strength of its users
despite folks like hancock being taken
aback when luffy demonstrated his hacky
power this is interesting but what makes
this
interesting to me is that becoming a
warlord of the sea was important to
blackbeard before
yet coming here i would think means that
he forfeits that title
so why is it okay or important to
forfeit the title in this
instance perhaps it's something warlords
are privy to that others aren't maybe
that he already saw and doesn't need to
see anymore
shuryu seems to be also in on it too i
mean he did let blackbeard slip right by
him at the top floor
regardless something big is happening
here and blackbeard says as much
stating that in a few hours they are
going to and i quote
put on a show that will shake the world
and with that he walks past the young
pirate
he is not after luffy in this instance i
have no idea what he's doing but i am
interested as the story progresses
through some amazing teamwork combining
the powers of the wax wax fruit with
luffy's abilities for both defensive and
offensive purposes it created a stunning
action sequence and a fantastic
redemption moment for mr three but all
is still not well as despite reaching
the top of impel down
and even after jinbe uses his abilities
to get them into the ship
they still have no means of escape as
once again the massive gate won't open
unless switched open from within the
facility
[Music]
this story that's right bon clay the
absolute
mad lad saves the freaking day again by
being just an
absolute genius and a selfless person
i really can't understand just how
ridiculously fun this climax was from
the teamwork to the commandeering of
ships to even
whale sharks summoned by jimbei all the
while having to think in the back of our
heads that black bear is after being
taken up by this poison guy which
apparently is okay to him
what and also the poison magellan guy is
on his way up to stop them in their
tracks before
they leave there and then now it was a
stunning masterclass in writing ending
with a very bittersweet finish as
banclay sacrifices himself
to let them run free and that's when we
see
this there's not much time left you know
before i started reading one piece i
mentioned that one of the only aspects
of the story that i knew about before
diving in was the one piece treasure
itself
and like many of you i would imagine i
was incredibly worried that the treasure
would be something like
the friends they made along the way or
something but given the journey we've
been on with the characters
in this series i almost wouldn't mind if
it was
and that's how good oda is his story is
so good i
actually feel like he's earned the
ending of the friends they made along
the way was the treasure
and i can already hear you typing down
below i know
that isn't the one piece treasure itself
i'm just saying i'm very aware that oda
cleared that up himself a long time ago
but more importantly this
arc was not only a stellar adventure
driven by emotion and tension unlike any
i've ever read before but it very much
also serves as a platform for oda to
show us all how ridiculously meticulous
and careful with his storytelling he can
be
and often is with very few plot points
encounters and reveals happening just
because oda thought it looked cool and
even less are unearned
and with this adventure through amazon
lily and impul down
two story arcs that hinge heavily on our
emotional connection to the straw hats
and our dedication in keeping up with
the secondary story threads in the hands
of a lesser or
even standard storyteller the events i
discussed in this video would not only
have felt contrived but also
boring and lifeless it's difficult to
try to convey just how impossible these
sort of arcs are or should have been to
pull off
with 90 percent of the main cast
literally absent and with the vast
majority of encounters depending on the
reader's dedication or willingness to
accept new characters into the fold
amazon lily and impul down stand for me
as monuments to the best manga story
i've ever in my life
read through as some of you who follow
me on twitter might already know i've
been going at this whole youtube thing
pretty hard for the last two years
straight
and while i love reading and writing for
these one piece videos
i think after my video next week i'll
need to take a break for a week or two
nothing too long just to recharge my
batteries
i hope youtube doesn't banish my channel
into obscurity because of that but
but if it does it would really mean a
lot to me if you subscribed and hit the
bell notification
to make sure that didn't happen and if
you'd still like to hear from me or ask
me any questions i'll still be on
twitter during that break too
my twitter handle is at totally not mark
however next week as i said i'll be
tackling the big finish to the arc
marine ford excited doesn't begin to
describe how pumped i am to see how this
saga
unfolds and concludes and lord knows i'm
not ready emotionally as so many of you
have warned me about but my hope is that
once again
you can join me on this adventure well
that'll do it for this video
as always i've been totally not mark
i'll see you all next week
and thank you so much for watching my
guess is that earthquakes are really so
scary because
you don't have any warning it's the only
thing besides a nuclear war that can
really
one second you're living in a big
beautiful city and 10 seconds later it's
flat